winning top honors in the documentary
category this year's director keiko
wright with her film hero
are stories of japanese internment
told through the eyes of her grandfather
the film made at new york university
documents the political hysteria racism
and scars evoked by japanese internment
during world war ii
first off i'd like to thank the academy
for this honor this week has been
absolutely amazing i have been telling
people i've been like a kid in a candy
store we have seen so many amazing
things and the people we have talked to
have been so generous with their time
and their
knowledge on the craft
i'd like to thank my family for all
their support i would like to thank my
crew
especially
reika shankar and jamie lee
as well as everyone who donated their
time and their talent
i would also like to thank my mentor at
nyu marsha moore who without whom i
would not be here tonight she was the
one who pushed me to enter the film
into
into here
lastly i would like to thank my
grandfather who
bravely shared his story with me and
allowed me to make this film
which i hope reminds all of us how
ever vigilant we have to be in
protecting each other's human and civil
rights and i'd like to thank you again
for this honor and i hope you guys all
check out everyone's films they're
amazing and keep up with all these
filmmakers because they're going to be
making amazing projects so thank you